en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos en
esta ocasión iniciamos hablando de
enfermedades zoonóticas es decir las que
surgen entre animales pero que se
adaptan para transmitirse al hombre
recientemente dos ejemplos fueron el coi
19 y la viruela del mono pues este
panorama hizo que el gobierno de uganda
construyera un laboratorio que rastrea
infecciones son ópticas en parques
nacionales donde muchas comunidades
conviven cerca de una gran variedad de
vida silvestre según expertos ugandeses
previamente era muy difícil hacer estos
diagnósticos en ese país
actualmente este laboratorio tiene tres
tipos de capacidades una podemos hacer
diagnósticos dos podemos hacer análisis
forenses es decir estamos desarrollando
una tubería para análisis forense
especialmente para la vida silvestre y
luego investigamos y cuando hacemos
investigación investigamos bacterias
patógenas protozoos patógenos también
investigamos patógenos virales
científicos estadounidenses estiman que
tres de cada cuatro enfermedades
infecciosas nuevas o emergentes en
humanos provienen de animales esto
porque las poblaciones se extienden e
invaden zonas donde antes sólo había
vida silvestre esto hace que los virus
mutan hasta volverse aptos para
contagiar humanos el laboratorio está
ubicado en muelle en el occidente del
país y se trata del primero de su tipo
en esta región
[Música]
y sabemos que las comunidades alrededor
especialmente en este parque se dedican
a comer vida silvestre cuando encuentran
cadáveres los comen especialmente los
cadáveres de hipopótamos
si alguien como un cadáver no sabe la
causa de la muerte si es un riesgo para
ellos porque no sabe que lo ha matado
qué pasa si es un patógeno que puede
matarte intercala chile desde que abrió
sus puertas hace unos meses el
laboratorio ya ha iniciado
investigaciones sobre posibles
enfermedades que podrían representar una
amenaza para la salud pública mundial
salimos de la tierra para ver las
últimas imágenes reveladas por la
agencia espacial europea y logradas
gracias al trabajo conjunto del super
telescopio espacial james webb y de su
predecesor el telescopio hubble se trata
de esta foto de la galaxia fantasma
también llamada m 74 esta galaxia está
ubicada a unos 32 millones de años luz
de distancia de la tierra en la
constelación piscis está casi de frente
a nuestro planeta la agencia indica que
se trata de una galaxia espiral conocida
como espiral de gran diseño esto quiere
decir que sus brazos son prominentes y
bien definidos a diferencia de las
estructuras irregulares y desiguales que
se ven en otras galaxias espirales la
labor del james webb fue revelar los
delicados filamentos de gas y polvo en
los brazos al tiempo que según explica
la esa la falta de gas en la región del
núcleo proporciona una vista despejada
del cúmulo de estrellas nucleares en el
centro de la galaxia el infrarrojo medio
del web permitió lograr más detalles de
las fases tempranas de formación de
estrellas en el universo local
vamos ahora a china donde un grupo de
científicos de la universidad de beijing
desarrolló un modelo de prótesis de
rodilla impresa en 3-d que se
personaliza para cada paciente y según
los responsables será clave para
personas que sufran de osteoartritis
los implantes ingresos en 3-d se
adaptarán muy bien a la rodilla y dos
harán menos sangrado la sangre saldría
del lugar donde se abrió el hueso y
siempre que la sección esté bien
cubierta no sangrara habrá menos
sangrado menos dolor y una recuperación
más rápida la característica más
importante de la prótesis articulares
que está demasiado estandarizada
la artrosis humana varía mucho tal como
lo expresó un ingeniero con el que
trabajamos todos tienen una cara
diferente y todos tienen una rodilla
diferente e incluso la rodilla en la
pierna izquierda es diferente de la que
está en la pierna derecha
tradicionalmente la cirugía de reemplazo
de rodilla requiere unos implantes
artificiales que muchas veces no son
adecuados para los pacientes por ello
con el nuevo plan quirúrgico se analiza
la información de cada persona y todos
los elementos quirúrgicos se
acondicionan de la forma más precisa los
responsables también exponen que el
tiempo de la cirugía se puede reducir
incluso a la mitad
y finalizamos en bangladesh puntualmente
en cox bazar donde miles de integrantes
de la minoría musulmana rohingya viven
en campamentos luego de huir de la
violencia en jean marc en uno de esos
campos vive do you como amat un joven de
15 años que construyó una pequeña
excavadora hidráulica con piezas
desechadas según lo que afirma cuando un
vivía en mianmar vio como trabajaba una
excavadora real y esto le sirvió de
inspiración
para operar este juguete uso agua en
jeringas inyección descubrí que las
jeringas funcionan para impulsar el
juguete tanto hacia arriba como hacia
abajo luego aplicó este mecanismo al
juguete su deuda en el a2 y tengo buenas
oportunidades espero poder convertirme
en un buen ingeniero para fabricar
grandes aviones y automóviles este es mi
objetivo convertirme en ingeniero en el
futuro ahora en línea momento manual de
loiu sólo recibió unos pocos años de
educación rudimentaria nyan mar antes de
que él y su familia se vieran obligados
a huir a bangladesh en 2017 desde
entonces sólo asistido a algunas clases
proporcionados por unicef en su
campamento para su educación está
actualmente en pausa debido a la
pandemia de ccoo y 19 el cuerpo de la
excavadora de juguete está hecho
principalmente de partes de acero y
clavos encontrados en la basura
alrededor de su campamento en cox bazar
en bangladesh la lana golán haining dora
a mí ya desde pequeño siempre ha jugado
con juguetes y trató de averiguar cómo
hacer un mecanismo como éste que se
mueva ya que siempre estaba ocupado con
sus juguetes me siento muy feliz de
verle hacer esto porque él también es
feliz ahora nos convertimos en refugio y
no tengo mucho dinero para enviarlo a
recibir una buena educación para que
pueda lograr cosas mejores dilemas de
equidad así llegamos al final de este
espacio a ustedes les agradecemos su
sintonía continúen con nosotros en
france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]